there she is
hey gigi
i don't think she likes you
oh she likes me she just doesn't know it
yet
my name is nate gibson i've been in this
wheelchair since i was 18. just jump
already
i was six weeks away from college
when i got paralyzed i had nurses around
the clock and one year ago my life
completely changed i'd like to request a
service animal for my son and that's
when i got gigi
she's a lot smaller than i thought
how's it going it's not coming out let's
try the peanut butter come on gigi look
at that
wow she's supposed to be helping me
carolyn said it would take time
[Music]
all the way now
oh man
[Music]
you can't keep a freaking monkey in the
house i wouldn't do that if i were you
look see you don't disturb her when
she's eating basic monkey 101
can i get a picture
hi a little monkey we should hang out
sometime she's never had this much
attention
you're trending this is so bad it's
everywhere
he can't be in here with that monkey
it's against the law she's a busybody
and i wanted to punch her right in her
botoxed face
but you're gonna take gigi away and i'm
never gonna see her again
[Music]
you have to fight you can't just let
them do that
you can't give up
[Music]
gigi allows me to live my life to the
fullest every single day
i wouldn't be here today if it wasn't
for her
he has a monkey well what do you want me
to do about it it's free country